we're joined today by abigail schreier
she's the author of the book
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters which is
out in paperback this week and you
should definitely pick it up because it
is and i've told her this
uh i think it's one of the most
important books
of this century which is not an
exaggeration
so first of all abigail congratulations
on the book and uh
thanks for writing it thanks for being
here thank you thank you so much for
having me on
so i want to talk about uh i want to
talk about two recent articles you wrote
but before that well we'll start with
the book
of course and the first thing i'm
curious about before we get to the
substance of the book
is the reaction to it i'm curious how
that's been for you clearly there are
plenty of people
out there like me who are grateful that
the book exists and that you wrote it
but i can imagine given that this is the
most toxic
subject in our culture today that you've
encountered some extremely intense
pushback which is probably an
understatement so how has that been over
the last year
you know it's been it's been wild um
it's really bifurcated the reaction so
you get
i'm completely flooded with with thank
you notes from
not only from parents but um therapists
doctors and and across the political
spectrum
i mean people are really grateful for
people who are willing to speak the
truth about what's what's going on
um the the then you have the small group
of very very energized activists
who who you know somehow
you know are really want want to rape me
apparently
um so it's it's a very strange sort of
position to be in
because because you do have these sort
of two extremes
and have they successfully i know
there's been campaigns to get the book
taken down from amazon or kicked out of
various booksellers but has that been
successful any of those efforts
well you know it's hard to to
to say i mean here's what i'll say you
know
it depends how you define success i mean
look at target so targetgood.com i sold
a lot of books because target.com
removed it after two
twitter activists complained they
removed the book
there was outcry i sold a lot of books
it sold out everywhere
they put the book back up for sale and
then the second no one was watching they
quietly deleted it again
so it's not available and has not been
for months and months and months has not
been available
target.com and you you see this testing
going on at
all over the place i mean i got a letter
the other day from
a man in vermont who had offered to
donate it to his library
and the library refused to take it this
is a book that people are on waiting
lists
to read and um you know libraries
won't you know very often won't carry it
they just refuse
um and and we're seeing that you know in
halifax nova scotia there was
there are 150 people on the list to read
the book and pride tried to shut it down
and have it removed on the grounds that
in in a library of literally over a
million volumes
this one book made them unsafe and the
library is do they give
a reason for not carrying it or
i can imagine what reason they would
give or would claim but do they give an
actual reason
sure are they anything from oh she's not
a medical doctor
which of course you know no journalist
who writes about any medical scandals
ever a medical doctor would just you
know that's why we interview experts
um to um you know this is not the
consensus view
well there is no consensus view that's
the problem
there's a lot of disagreement within the
medical community how this should be
handled
unfortunately what's going on right now
is a real medical scandal
and the few doctors you know who are
willing to
speak up really risk losing their
license
and of course the thing about the book
is you're you're allowing
for the vast majority of the book is
you're allowing other people to simply
tell their stories so it's not like it's
it didn't come across to me as
polemical at all it was just this this
these this is what's happening here are
the stories
and i'm just sharing them with you
that's that's what the book is yeah i
didn't i didn't start
um with a belief and i don't you know i
have never pushed a policy prescription
or anything like that with regard to
this you know transgender health care i
just pointed out
you know i did an exploration of the the
sudden
rise out of nowhere of teenage girls
deciding they were transgender
i looked at why why are they suddenly
the
leading demographic we have a hundred
year diagnostic history of this thing
called gender dysphoria the severe
discomfort and once biological sex and
it was always boys and men and now
overwhelmingly the leading demographic
is teenage girls across the west and
and i wanted to look at why why that
might be
and i explored you know i talked to a
lot of experts who offer a lot of
different reasons
and uh that's what i explored in the
book yeah so let's continue along with
that because
to me the book was eye-opening on a
number of level levels and
originally i didn't think i i spent a
lot of time talking about this subject
as well and
and researching it and i like to think
i'm pretty aware of what's going on
so at first i was skeptical that that
honestly the book could tell me anything
i didn't already know
uh but it did actually have quite quite
a bit that i didn't know and
the first is the most basic thing like
you just mentioned that this is uh
really especially among kids this is a
phenomenon that is
affecting girls the most i had always
thought of it as a primarily
male phenomenon so can you talk you
mentioned you want to explore why
girls are so susceptible if you could
summarize why
that is i mean why why are they so
susceptible teenage girls
in mental health distress anxiety
depression and other you know
anything from borderline personality
disorder to other um you know
psychological struggles have always been
susceptible to pure contagion
they've always been susceptible to the
idea that there's something really wrong
with them
and that if they just lose enough weight
or
you know um if they get control these
multiple personalities
or i mean there's a you know they they
come up with these explanations
sometimes they're introduced from by
therapists in this case it's all over
the culture
and the and social media and the ideas
they look to the culture to figure out
what's wrong with them
and today the the answer that they're
landing on
is oh i know what the problem is i'm
supposed to be a boy and the moment a
young person says that a young woman
says that
she goes from a lonely teenager who may
struggle to find friends to someone who
is celebrated in her school
congratulated by her therapist and whose
doctor
can't wait to start her on a course of
hormones so this is kind of
uh we're taking these universal feelings
that that all teenagers experience
especially girls
and what we have now is a they're being
presented with a with a
handy kind of framework for
understanding those feelings and that's
what brings them to
transgenderism basically that's right i
mean imagine you know a young woman who
you know
prior era would have who would be
anorexic and be convinced that if she
just lost enough weight
everything would be better it's very you
know they they latch on to the because
they are in real pain
this does not discount their pain we
know that rates are
very high of anxiety depression
self-harm for this
generation and they're in they're in a
lot of pain and they looked
you know psychological pain is very hard
to explain to someone
in a way that gets you noticed and in a
way that gets you
you know um interest and help
and what they want they want they want
the affection they want the celebration
and they want the attention
and one way to frame it so that they get
those things
um which which i think they do need they
do need attention they do need
compassion
but the way that they're framing it is
is not necessarily accurate in fact very
often i think it's inaccurate that what
they what they have
is not real typical gender dysphoria
that's that's what gets me when i when i
listen to uh
people taught whether it's kids or even
adults oftentimes
talking about their discovery that
they're another gender
and you hear things like well i i didn't
feel comfortable in my body
um i knew i just knew that i was
different and those kinds of things and
i always think well
yeah but that's that's a that's a pretty
universe it's real
and it's it's a serious thing and it's
not to discount it but at the same time
these also sound like pretty universal
human feelings i i wonder if there's any
person on earth who's never felt
uh uncomfortable in their body or like
they didn't fit in but now we just have
this framework
do you think we're at the point now
where for
kids it's it's looked down upon
in their peer groups to be just sort of
a normal person who identifies as the
sex they were born with
we're at the point now where that's even
where it's it's you you would be
embarrassed
to be a quote unquote cisgender as a kid
your parents tell me that all the time i
see that all the time you see parents
you know and indeed transitioners young
women who regretted their transition
talk about that all the time um on
social media these young women are
constantly coached
in you know gender ideology and told
that oh if you feel uncomfortable every
woman goes through a period
around puberty of feeling uncomfortable
in her body and she's taught
and and they spend tremendous amount of
times on social time on social media
they're taught that that feeling means
you're transgender at a time when it's
very uncool to be a straight girl
who is cisgender you know you know
comfortable in her body at all
so the the the number of forces pushing
on her
to declare this identity or a lot and
the one as soon as she declares a trans
identity or non-binary identity
um the next question is oh yeah okay
let's prove it when are you going to
start with surgeries and hormones so
how is this happening so quickly that's
one question i get a lot
i i don't feel like i have a really
sufficient answer for it but because i
you know i was in high school
in the from 2000 2004
and uh i think it wasn't all that long
ago and
i tran transgenderism as a concept
existed i think i
heard of it a few times i didn't have
anyone in my school that identified that
way
um and we've gone from that to in a
matter of
a couple decades now it's we're at a
point now where if you're if you if you
identify as just quote-unquote cisgender
it's strange
so this is a rapid extreme
change in our culture how did it happen
so quickly do you think
well the activists were able to corrupt
many
institutions so the activists and they
are extremely
extremely aggressive were able to
corrupt both the public school system
and infiltrate it with gender ideology
which teaches kids in california they
start at
age five teaching them that only you
know your true gender
um not you know not the doctor the
doctor assigns your gender randomly but
only
you know your real one and you if you
declare it here it's a safe space we
don't have to tell your parents
so that was one force but also the
therapists
were put under tremendous pressure to go
along with this we have conversion
therapy bands in 20 states in america
now which say that if you
if a therapist tries to convert you out
of your
supposed gender identity in other words
to translate
if a gender if a therapist actually just
tries to get you comfortable in your
body and say wait a second i know you
say your problem is that you're you were
born into this body but
what about the other things we haven't
explored um the the therapist
is at risk of losing their license um
and then
when i looked into medical organizations
nearly all of them had adoptive
affirmative care which means it's their
now their job of doctors
to rubber stamp the patient's
self-diagnosis when it comes to this one
diagnosis gender dysphoria
so with the affirmative care laws and
how many states did you say had those
20 states have conversion therapy bans
okay so
and conversion therapy is if you if you
help a boy
remain a boy then you are converting him
into what he already is
which makes a lot of sense but is it
so the if affirmative care so if a if a
child comes into
the counselor and says the experience
they're experiencing confusion about
their gender or discomfort
the therapist is not allowed to explore
any other cause for that confusion or
discomfort they have to they have to
immediately
jump to gender dysphoria and
transgenderism is that is that what it
is
well that's effectively what affirmative
care pressures them to do
and if they go against that they are at
risk of losing their license they could
easily be accused of running a foul of
the standard
which is don't don't try to convert a
child into the
into being cisgender um obviously this
grew out of the
anti-homosex conversion um
you know process you know attempts that
were you know
historically could be quite grisly um
and so
they passed these laws and people
unthinkingly went along with them
even though they had inserted gender
identity language into the bands
now gender dysphoria historically was
always treated holistically it was
always treated
with wait a second i know you think your
problem is gender but let's talk about
how you arrived at that why don't you
want to be a boy i mean that's the kind
of exploration
that therapy really required um now it's
prohibited
yeah i don't have a i've confessed i
don't have a lot of experience with
therapy but i had always thought of
therapy as sort of the opposite of
affirming because
you're going in there with uh with
feelings or psychological troubles that
you don't want to affirm do you want to
be you want to be freed of them that's
what i always thought of it as
uh right and same thing with doctors you
never started out with the conclusion
today we start with the conclusion you
have gender dysphoria and then the
question is when do we start the
medication
and speaking of doctors so i think a lot
of people don't
um a lot of people don't realize
how bad the medical part of this is for
kids a quote unquote medical so
how does that work you got a 13 year old
kid
diagnosed with gender dysphoria um and
they're put on the medical
track how does that how does that play
out and do we do we get to the point
where they're doing actual surgeries
potentially
while the child is still a child still a
minor so it depends if they have
parental permission and it depends on
the state
so yes they absolutely do do it on
minors
the surgeries um with parental
permission whether they can do it
without
parental permission varies by state um
but
but you know this is an area in which
unfortunately
a lot of very good doctors who who are
really uncomfortable with these
treatments
have bowed out and they bowed out
because they know listen i don't want to
do this
um you know this is that we're really
pushing kids to something they may
they're very likely to regret so the
best doctors very often bow out of even
doing this kind of medicine and instead
you have the most aggressive activist
doctors who can't wait to make the
really considerable remuneration that it
offers
do you know how young potentially
the the surgeries are happening i mean
are they happening 16
15 younger than that well in california
13
with parental permission 13. yeah 13
year old girls have been
you know had double mastectomies um you
know
without parental permission you know you
can get it in
in oregon the state you know the state
will cover it and allow it at 15.
but it varies by state have you talked
to any parent you talked to a lot of
parents in the book i don't remember a
parent like this though
have you talked to a parent that
actually gave their 13 year old
permission to have her breasts
cut off have you talked to any parents
like that no i talked to parents who
were planning to do that
who are planning to go along with it at
that young of an age
had that yet um well uh parents
in one case it was a boy so it was
planning to start on the blockers um
you know i talked to parents who were
you know considering or planning to go
on blockers but i didn't talk to anyone
who had
agreed to remove uh the girl's breasts
so let's stay on the parents for a
minute um and you you talk a lot about
you have a whole parent you have a
chapter on parents and then
of course they're featured prominently
throughout because they're a big part of
the story
uh you highlight many parents who are
blindsided by their child's trans
identification
and which is a really tragic situation
those parents are in i can't imagine
what it's like for them and i think that
that probably
as you as you explore in the book that
probably happens frequently with
adolescents who go this route because
they pick up this stuff in school or
youtube and then all of a sudden they're
blindsiding the kids but my view is that
uh young children
you know five six seven or younger than
that who quote come out as trans
my my assumption is that like in a
hundred percent of those cases
that was pushed on them by the parents
because i don't see how a kid
could go that route at that young of an
age without the parent being very much
involved in it um do you think i'm being
unfair to the parents with with that
assumption
what role do you think the parents play
exactly here so i think there are
a few and a few different parts um or
a few different cases to consider so we
know that
kids have had gender dysphoria we have a
very long diagnostic history so
are have there been kids who said no
mommy i'm not a boy i'm a girl
from a very young age yes there have
been those kids without parent
parents necessarily pushing it yes there
have
um now the transgender identity
okay that that is something that is
typically and we know that it's
introduced by the culture and that's not
something we ever did with kids before
i mean they might have you know had some
gender confusion
about who they really were but we didn't
it immediately today it's getting
validated all over the place
um and it is also true that i've
interviewed parents who say that their
kid is transgender
and it is true that when you ask them oh
no he always wore
you know he always loved nail polish you
know from the age
four when you ask well how did he get
the nail polish
you know very often the parents did
supply it
right and why should liking nail polish
be an indication
of anything other than the kid thinks
that that looks cool that you have paint
on your hands
i mean this is one of the i can never
get a straight answer on this but
when a when a five-year-old boy let's
say says i'm a girl what is that
statement even supposed to mean given
that the five-year-old boy and i have
four kids um they have no idea what a
girl even is they that
that it seems to me that when a if a boy
makes that statement what he's really
saying is if he's saying anything
what he's really saying is something
like um you know i
i see the dollhouse that my sister's
playing with and i think it's cool and i
want to play with it too
why does this have to be anything more
significant than that and i can never
get a straight answer on that
so when you interview as i have like the
best gender therapists
um who many of whom have been basically
run out of town i mean
meaning like giants in the field of
gender dysphoria have been canceled by
the activist but when you interview men
like ken zucker
or ray blanchard you know ken
used to work with children and he would
absolutely push back and explore
where did you get that idea oh you know
let's talk about it
because you know he was the therapist he
didn't think the child was some sort of
prophet
but today these young children are
treated as prophets the moment that they
um you know declare they have they are
uncomfortable in their bodies and their
gender
they're treated as prophets and then the
question just begins what you know
the next question is just when do we
start right
now i uh i did want to get to two of
these articles that you've written
um the first for the city journal
journal's headline when the state comes
for your kids
and it's uh bone-chilling stuff but
i wanted to let you summarize it because
you'll do a better job than me can you
just tell us what what that piece is
about
and what do you mean the state coming
for your kid
so i i looked at the laws of washington
oregon and california because i was
getting calls from parents
that their custody was being threatened
if they didn't go along with the idea
that their troubled teens were
transgender
and i looked at both what the laws
allowed
in um in many cases really allow not
only
in well to take the case of washington a
13 year old has total control of his or
her mental health care
including and this includes gender
affirming care
and insurers
are blocked from even sharing
information or medical care
with the parents so
kids of 13 and up have total control
over their own mental health care
parents don't even get to know about it
they're not even notified by the
insurers they're not allowed to be
notified by doctors
and what you had was a situation and
there are these safe houses all over
which is very which are very hard to
extricate your kid from
um if they've shown up at so we had this
we had i kept getting calls
that people were losing their kids to
the system
who weren't bad parents in fact they
were loving parents desperate to get
their kids
um back the only the only thing they had
done wrong
was that they had failed to um they had
they had declined to affirm the kids new
you know
gender identity and someone in the state
found out about that
um that's i mean it's
horrific how widespread
is that would you would you consider
these cases so far to be extreme
exceptions or is this
really becoming an endemic problem i
think it's increasingly an endemic
problem i'll tell you why first of all a
lot of the parents who called me
couldn't even talk i mean i i guess i i
profiled five or six for these
article i wrote but i was contacted by
many others who said i'm so sorry you
can't
this is you know we can't i can't tell
you anything more about this because
there's an ongoing case right now
the number of parents there are a lot of
parents in court right now fighting to
get their kids back
who won't talk because they're terrified
there are parents who have lost custody
who are afraid that if they
if they ever you know say anything to me
that their kid will find out and then
the kid will never talk to them again
so i think it's much more widespread
than i was even able to include in the
article
but you're also seeing you know a
generation
of extremely woke um not only social
workers
therapists but increasingly you know
we're going to see
doc doctors we already see woke doctors
we're also going to see woke judges as
these young woke
people who are real gender ideologues
start becoming appointed judges
and i think this is a problem that you
see across the whole the whole landscape
here
um when we talk about how widespread the
problem is
that in so many of these areas a lot of
people affected by it
can't talk about it or are afraid to
talk about it because of the
professional repercussions and another
great example of that
uh the other article you wrote for a
wall street journal about in the
the the situation in women's prisons
where men
are being um are being sent into women's
prisons
and there's certainly a place where
these these women have no
voice um and they they have no real way
unless someone like you comes along they
have no way to get their story out there
so can you talk about that uh a little
bit these these are men
who if i understand correctly and i
guess it depends depends on the state a
little bit but
they don't have to have surgery or
anything right they uh not that that
even would make it okay but they don't
have surgery or anything right
these these are just men who are being
put in women's prisons because they
declare
that they feel like women yeah and they
so i talked to the women of the chow
chila prison which is the highest
security it's
technically called the central
california uh correctional facility
colloquially
known as the chowchilla prison and this
is the highest security women's prison
in the state of california
these women are tough women but they are
terrified because
now a new law allows men biological men
to transfer in
all they need to do is declare a female
identity no surgery or hormones are
required for them to become eligible for
transfer
and the reason and that we have these
laws in a few states now washington
um has the same policy a woman was raped
by one of the biological men who was
placed in her prison
um i've been in you know um sorry there
there have been serial rapists
who are declared a female identity and
were put in women's prison in the state
of washington
and the problem is even more serious
than and dire than i you know
that i was able to convey because in the
future
as these laws you know continue to exist
um right now the men are transferring
into women's prison from men's prison so
we can track
them but you know in laws like
washington
where you can just change your birth
certificate
and in california where you go into the
system now as a female
it will be extremely difficult for
reporters to even be able to track
who who these men were it will look like
women on women violence when they rape
and assault the female inmates
and part of the problem right is that in
women women's prisons a lot of them
anyway they don't
they don't segregate based on the
severity of crime as strictly as they do
in men's prisons because there isn't as
much violence to begin with
until you start putting the men in there
um so you could have
you know a man convicted of murder in
there with women who
what you know shoplifted or something
right well
yeah i mean one thing that i learned
from the women prisoners which i didn't
know
and i was able to corroborate was that a
lot of not only
are a huge number of female prisoners uh
abused survivors sexual abuse survivors
but very often when they committed
crimes and they committed a lot of these
women committed very serious crimes
they did it at the at the behest of a
scary man they were involved with
so um these are women who are have been
pushed around by men their whole lives
um and um are even though you know
these are very tough women um the men
transferring in the men
male convicts are are quite quite scary
um they're huge often they are extremely
strong
and they can easily overpower them and
these women are terrified
you mentioned the one case of a woman
who was raped
by a male prisoner sent in there are you
aware of any other cases because it
strikes me that this
is probably happening a lot just given
what we're doing here the how we're
mixing things together um but it also
strikes me that we would
we would never find out about it so are
you aware of any other
cases uh like that it's it's
i i am not and i'll tell you why it's
very complicated because you hear even
from the women
that the men who are in there can very
often even if there's a sexual
relationship it's hard to tell if it's
consensual
and the reason is is the women are
trapped in small cells with them
so the women will in some cases will say
that the
it is consensual um but but a lot of the
you know other prisoners disbelieve that
um
given how much much stronger the men are
and how trapped the women feel
and and remember these these cells women
are the
women's cells are everyone is just
together there aren't
you don't because women are less violent
they're not set up to keep people
separate or to safeguard women
from each other so the men who enter
really have free reign
uh one other thing on this this seems to
me well
the whole thing really but especially
when it comes to women's prisons you've
got a real women's rights issue here
has there been um any interest among the
metoo crowd
left-wing feminists at all have they
shown any interest in this story and
wanted to follow up on it or anything
like that
no um women you know feminist groups
today i mean i think just this week the
national
organization of women declared that
trans women are women
and are to be treated as such um
feminists organizations in general in
america have completely betrayed women
they can't wait to give away women's
rights
and they couldn't care less about uh
the female prisoners who are not only a
very vulnerable population they have no
political crap
clout so no one's looking out for them
democratic politicians don't care
by and large republicans don't either
they don't vote
um so there's no natural constituency
you you just have to have something of a
conscience to care about what happens to
these women
and there aren't a lot of people with
those walking around these days uh so
last question going full circle here uh
back to your book
out in paperback this week uh you have
you have a chapter in the end on on
the way back and i have to be honest
i don't i'm i'm a bit cynical which is
an understatement but i don't really see
a way back from this culturally
uh but you do so so what is the the way
back
i do with this because you know this is
just
really just a a blizzard of lies
and if we can call a lot of them out i
do think we can get through this
um one of the things to to protect your
kids from
is well first of all is to be aware of
the lies so for instance i was just
speaking to a woman the other day who
said oh i called my daughter's school
to make sure there's no sex education
you know that involves gen
j uh to for the five-year-olds and i
explained in the book how california hid
gender orient gender identity um
education
in the soji curriculum which is not part
of sex ed
it's part of the anti-bullying
curriculum so there's a lot of
there really there's a lot of duplicity
around this
but i think just as we're becoming aware
of the critical race theory in the
schools
you know the more we're aware of the
gender ideology in the schools the more
we can demand that this
this madness be stopped there's no
reason to indoctrinate an
entire student population and gender
confusion um
you know you can throw you can show
compassion to trans gender identified
kids without doing that and
and we need to demand it but another
thing is social media we've got to get
the kids off the social media
this is just so obvious i know it's hard
but you're talking about skyrocketing
rates of anxiety depression
self-harm these kids are showing up at
the hospitals
you know for for attempted suicide
younger than we've ever seen before
and and the stakes are just too high
yeah i uh it certainly has to begin
at a minimum with uh with reclaiming
your child's attention rather than
letting
you know youtube influencers and so on
um
guide them through life so maybe there
is maybe there is a little bit of hope
and i appreciate that you could at least
end on end on that note
again the book is uh is irreversible
damage the transgender craze seducing
our daughters which is out in paperback
this week definitely pick up the book
abigail schreier
thanks a lot for joining us and for the
conversation i appreciate it
thank you
you